parece una ciudad que acaba de ser
destruida por una explosión los árboles
en el suelo y los tejados volando son la
prueba de la potencia del impacto el
pasado mes de febrero dos huracanes bats
irak y en nat y azotaron la costa
oriental dejando tras de sí una ciudad
desangrada y miles de personas sin hogar
sin comida ni agua entre ellos está
agita de 29 años madre soltera de dos
hijos aquí está mi plato señora si bien
no ves que estoy repartiendo estas
distribuciones estatales se limitan a un
plato al día un trozo de pollo arroz y
verduras para el alojamiento y otras
comidas cita tendrá que valerse por sí
misma nuestra casa ya había sufrido un
incendio esta vez está completamente
destruida no tenemos adónde ir hago un
llamado al presidente para que nos ayuda
con esta situación
el presidente malgache acudió en persona
tras el paso del huracán bat shirai y se
inyectaron decenas de millones de
dólares de ayuda internacional en las
operaciones de emergencia pero aquí 1300
de los 5500 hogares siguen sin vivienda
aquí es donde estaba nuestra casa estaba
allí nuestro techo se derrumbó ahora
como en el suelo entre los escombros
por favor señora puede prestarme una
cuchara para que mi hijo pueda comer
tienes que darle las gracias ahora me
cuesta comiendo pero a veces no es
suficiente comida para él y tengo que
probarme porque tiene mucho apetito
esta noche gitano comerán y pasará la
noche bajo las estrellas ya que no hay
espacio disponible en un refugio de
emergencia
y otro primero arreglar la cama para mis
hijos
estoy pasando estoy levantando esto
aquí es donde voy a acostar a mis hijos
a mi hermana aquí es donde los voy a
instalar para que duerman
mañana saldré temprano en la mañana a
buscar un trabajo ya encontrar algo para
alimentar a estos niños
refugio comida el huracán arrasó con los
derechos humanos básicos el más
importante es el acceso al agua potable
las inundaciones mezclaron las aguas
residuales con el agua limpia esta
situación se ve agravada por la
defecación al aire libre ampliamente
practicada en la región para limitar las
enfermedades causadas por el consumo de
agua sucia
unicef está distribuyendo kits de
purificación de agua pero lo más
importante es animar a la gente a
cambiar sus malos hábitos si nuestras
heces se esparcen en la naturaleza
infectarán el agua del canal de pangal
danés y se las comerán los peces y a
dónde van estos peces a sus platos de
edad es posible que los peces se coman
tus heces y por lo tanto tú te comas tus
heces les gustaría eso
ya está por eso hay que seguir con las
buenas prácticas usar el baño y poner
los excrementos de los niños en el vale
a medida que se multiplican los casos de
diarrea y fiebre tifoidea las ong
quieren evitar una epidemia a la que el
hospital público de marankiari no podría
hacer frente porque el ciclón bat shirai
voló su techo y dañó gran parte de sus
equipos y medicamentos desde entonces se
han realizado partos en estas tiendas de
emergencia gracias a los equipos
instalados con las ong
la falta en la tienda pharma lotto
estoy muy agradecida por haber dado a
luz allí
pero lo que me entristece a nuestra casa
ha sido destruida y si sale mañana
tendremos que vivir con alguien esta
situación me angustia
mientras que el manjar y se ha
convertido en el nuevo santuario de las
ong otros municipios han sido
prácticamente olvidados nos dirigimos
anocíbar y acá a 115 km al norte debido
al desastroso estado de la carretera
agravado por dos ciclones es necesario
ir en barco en el momento de nuestra
visita no había ninguna ong presente
solo la ayuda estatal 23 kilos de arroz
por hogar suficiente para 15 días la
distribución organizada seis días
después del ciclón desencadenó en unos
disturbios provocados por el hambre al
sospechar una apropiación indebida los
residentes saquearon las existencias la
policía hace tiros al aire desde hace un
mes marco line y su familia no reciben
nada la única solución de la subida de
precios es recurrir ante busca
a veces compro arroz a crédito y reveló
a un comerciante con un margen para
poder devolver el préstamo mi mensaje al
gobierno es que tenemos hambre 300
gramos de arroz cuestan 19 céntimos de
dólar almorzamos pero no sé si voy a
encontrar algo para comer esta noche
el banco mundial ha destinado cerca de
40 millones de dólares a los programas
de emergencia por su parte el estado
sigue trabajando en un programa de
reconstrucción de infraestructuras que
los donantes internacionales esperan con
impaciencia para activar la ayuda
adicional mientras tanto la precariedad
causada por el cambio climático hace
quemar colina y cientos de miles de
víctimas de catástrofes sean cada vez
más vulnerables